hello reject nation Greg Johnson pub
which one is this the Deadpool of Y at
the Deadpool infinity war I'm excited to
see this I like the villain pub segments
that they do for we do that I want to
say thank you to everyone who's been
joining our patreon for the month of
April so much support from you guys I
love all of you over there we do weekly
Q&A is full-length TV show reactions to
plenty of shows we want to give a patron
the day shout out to none other than
Derek Mitchell
so Derek Derek haven't talked to you in
a while buddy start chatting with you
again today right before you were on
your way to see infinity war spoiler
Batman and Superman have the same name
that's right Derek Mitchell is a very
kind-hearted dude as passion is working
with the computers currently right now
as a lyft and uber driver I'm telling
you guys if you are hoping you are one
of those people who ends up a victim in
a lyft or uber ride refer ibly kidnapped
and murdered in the woods make sure that
you hit up your lyft or uber app when
Derek Mitchell is working when you see
those ads for Hulu when they talk about
are you scared to get a lyft and uber
ride it's because of guys like Derek
Mitchell look out Kansas the D train is
on the move figure nice last time come
on as well let's villain paws Phillipa
maybe Derek will be in the video it's in
theme
[Music]
use a song laughing sure does take a lot
thinking of ways to distribute K takes
everything you've got
[Music]
you wanna go sweetie
[Music]
Pano's to find absolutely nothing but
it's being treated as the scariest band
of all time
let's give em a tour importer okay okay
he's finally going to do something who's
up for a little wager going to kids did
somebody say dead well not you Deadpool
it's an actual Deadpool now get out of
here you're gonna have a dead bull
without the real Deadpool don't you know
how profitable I'll see you later okay
that house who wants the first degree
Oh put me down
for zero what yeah
yes zero it's marble the good guys
always win new who do works over my
yondu I'm just sick huh huh but you
already get away a lot next I'm going to
say five thirty kids Iron Man
because he's like a good dad and that
would be really hard to watch Doctor
Strange because he's got to have magic
taken out of the picture the Incredible
Hulk
because you're super strong hawkeye
because oh yeah I think it's going to be
Captain America Captain America
you just said Captain America three
times because I want to do 33 times
let's go three captains oh yeah totally
gonna do Oh put me down for lookie
faking his death and then killing Thanos
sleep I'm just saying
[Music]
apocalypse leaks the x-men are going to
show up anyone else I bet he only gets
two I bet it's vision and Scarlet Witch
oh yes my vote now
I forgot has stone you can't change
black widow drags war machine oh no is
if you kill crude I'm gonna be totally
pissed ha what he's adorable
what about you pops what are you Minh
how come she's going to kill every last
one of them
so it's apt another doc they will work
together to destroy us whoo girls are so
annoying is that everyone no one thinks
he's going to tell a black pad I'm gonna
kill Black Panther I will be commercial
suicide it's like doing a Deadpool video
without actually having dead guys it's
finally my time I'm off to destroy the
universe
you guys were fun you guys into big
broad smile rushes I hope they remember
you
[Music]
[Music]
Wow it is so tempting to not so tempting
to start spoiling ya the circles be
running it kinda feels like we just
talked about I know we can't yeah who
did well or did better than others so
tempting oh nice theory on on Palpatine
for how the next movie is gonna go
dedicating their whole villain pub to
determine who will die in infinity war
yeah it's a really funny concept cuz you
so giddy at like these fun inserts of
everyone I just love that little touch
Masada with the priests around his neck
Zod is like the one guy who's like
really into these yeah I also appreciate
it just I remember talking about Thanos
in the lead-up to infinity war early on
being like Hollies does like sit in a
chair yeah I'm not scary they've been
also like to hear them touch upon that
was pretty great yeah I'm pretty funny
immediately when they said that I was
like oh how different of a viewing
series of this video have been if I had
gosh the whole discussion of us I still
think this video was funny and I thought
like I'm like the last one that we saw
which is just funny there's kind of like
a plot a sharper sketch I feel sure yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a better
structured sketch well it's amusing to
watch the different personalities and
the different villains you know pick who
they think yeah and I get wiped out with
why I should have their opinions on a
joke or kind of dishing out his opinion
I'm horrible if you look closely at the
board like I love the different names
because not everybody is even like a big
hero it's like Ned's on the board the
collectors on the board president how it
should have ended you know like a lot of
channels will have like that main
driving segment they do other stuff and
it doesn't do as well anything they do
does well yeah it's more than just how
it should have ended it's very
impressive how they have like
villain pub and those musical parodies
and then his scene yeah very impressive
good for these guys or hard-ass for a
long time as villain pub is is just as
huge as they're freaking hizzy normal
segments bad news
you know should be in the villain pubs
Derek Mitchell yeah those lift lift
rides alright guys well my thoughts are
kind of just blocked yeah you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell Derek Mitchell I
love you more than your mom loves you
that's because she rejects you for your
serial killer waste slide in those DMS